the u.s death toll in the coronavirus
pandemic has now surpassed
a quarter of a million people by far the
highest
national toll worldwide infections are
soaring
to new highs across the country new york
city
was the epicenter of the u.s outbreak
earlier this year
now it's decided to close all public
schools again
as it fights resurgence in the virus
it's an unseasonably early last week of
school for children across new york city
classrooms are shifting to online
learning until further notice
it's the latest in a series of new
restrictions in the state
parents and students alike are unhappy
it's super unfortunate that these kids
are going to be denied
an education but we can go eat dinner
inside a restaurant
for tomorrow to be the last day of
school it kind of sucks
we're a little sad it's closed but if
that's what's best for the kids
we'll go with it the city's mayor feels
the same way
i want to affirm that as much as we are
unhappy today that this moment was
reached
we are resolved to keep fighting that's
what new yorkers do and we will overcome
this moment
cases in the state have more than
doubled over the past two weeks
but new york isn't the only state to see
an exponential rise
caseloads across the country are
increasing as are new restrictions
deaths have also been mounting passing
quarter of a million since the start of
the pandemic
the president-elect is warning even more
people could die if president trump
refuses to share crucial information
with the incoming administration
over 300 million americans that are and
beyond
our our border that are going to have to
be taken care of
and there's a whole lot of things that
are just
we just don't have available to us which
unless it's made available soon we're
going to be behind
by weeks or months even as
promising vaccines raise the hope of an
end to the crisis
the country will still have to endure a
long winter
well for more let's bring in dr peter
chin hong he's an infectious disease
specialist at the university of
california san francisco
dr xin hong more than 250 000
deaths how did things get this bad in
the u.s
well it's a combination of factors terry
uh
there is colder weather some more people
are drawn indoors
there is pandemic fatigue which some
have recoined
pandemic resentment and of course um
you know uh people are still in search
of a national strategy we still don't
have one it's several months many months
into the
pandemic and we're only as good as our
neighbors given the fact that we have
very porous borders
between states now there are two
highly effective anti-covered vaccines
on the horizon they could be
approved possibly in a matter of weeks
what are your expectations
in terms of impact from those vaccines
on the pandemic in the u.s
well terry i think i would approach it
with very cautious
optimism i think it'll be some time
before
much of the general population sees the
vaccine of course
only about 50 to 60 percent of americans
by the latest pool are even uh
willing to stick their arms out to get
the vaccine tomorrow
but we will be doing it in tears with
the healthcare workers
and first responders first
then with folks who are co-morbid
conditions
and the elderly what's the situation in
your clinic
and others like it when it comes to
treating covet-19 patients do you have
the resources you need
well we've been stockpiling masks we've
been stockpiling
drugs like rem de severe over the last
few months
but i still think we will run short in
certain key areas like diagnostic
supplies uh there's been a run on
individuals trying to get
covet tests and um we're not
able to keep up with demand right now
but i would say it's the car before the
storm
and we expect a two-week lag between
what we see in the community in terms of
cases
and what we see in the hospital
hopefully we're not going to get
overrun because we only have limited
beds
president-elect joe biden is warning
that more people may die if donald trump
continues to block
transition planning with the coronavirus
what do you make of that
i think it's a very uh realistic
statement to make given the fact that
you know even as something as as key and
vital like
vaccine rollout like you described terry
is uh
up in obscurity right now because we
don't know
how the military is going to be involved
the new administration doesn't know
how the refrigeration or the freezing is
going to be rolled out because
as you know both of these mrna vaccines
require very cold temperatures
to get to the arms of the patients who
need it so all these key
details i'm missing from the new
administration
from the public health officials dr
peter chen hong
of the infectious infectious disease
specialist at the university of san
francisco in california thank you so
much
thanks so much terry well
in the u.s the food and drug
administration has given
emergency approval to the first rapid
coronavirus test that can be done at
home after a simple nasal swab the
result positive or negative appears in
about 30 minutes
this test does require a doctor's
prescription but it bypasses the lengthy
process of waiting for results from a
lab
now this is good news against a global
backdrop of
restrictions and lockdowns here in
europe there is a
patchwork of national responses to the
corona
virus now this map shows all of the
countries that have imposed a partial
or total nationwide lockdown as it
stands tonight there are
17 countries that go from austria which
began a total lockdown on tuesday you've
got germany which is in the middle
of a four week partial lockdown stores
schools are open restaurants bars and
gyms are closed
the world health organization says that
more than half of new infections
reported
worldwide last week came from
europe now the situation is worse in the
united states what we see here
are the states that have issued a stay
at home
order similar to european lockdowns and
as you see
here new mexico is the only state that
does that they're supposed to be color
coded
new mexico is the only state that is
telling people that they have to stay
home other states are advising that they
do that which is california
you see there kentucky and then in the
northeast we have the states of
massachusetts and rhode island
well the day's best news in the pandemic
is a transatlantic story
the u.s pharmaceutical giant pfizer and
germany's biontech
have announced that their coronavirus
vaccine has passed all safety tests and
trials biontech's ceo
says regulators in europe and the u.s
could approve the vaccine as early as
december our safety analysis so far
indicates and that that the vaccine
is very tolerated it could happen that
that we
we get an authorization yeah um
in yeah until mid of december and could
start
to to provide the first millions of
doses of vaccines
to the to the regions where we get an
approval on authorization
all right for more now on the latest in
the covid vaccine race i'm joined by
amish adalja he's a senior scholar at
johns hopkins center for
public for health security it's good to
have you on
the program the the pfizer biontech
vaccine it has taken just 10 months
to develop which is a remarkably short
time
how can we be sure that it's safe
we can be sure that it is safe because
we've seen animal data we've seen phase
one and phase two and now phase three
data
you have to remember that the speed with
this with with this vaccine was made
had to do with the fact that it was
using a new technology an mrna vaccine
platform
and that's where we cut the speed down
it wasn't that the safety was
that there were corners cut in phase one
or two trials we will have to follow
people once they're vaccinated for years
like we do with all vaccines but in the
middle of a pandemic we're going to get
an emergency use authorization
based on the the safety data that we
have so far
and it does look good i do think we have
to continue to follow as i said
to make sure nothing longer term occurs
but i do think everything is
is pointing the right way when it comes
to this vaccine amish are you concerned
that there are
no long-term observations with this
vaccine
i'm not concerned in the sense that
anytime we have a vaccine it gets
approved
and then we follow people out in what
are called phase four trials so
when the hpv vaccine was that was
approved
we didn't have two or three or four
years of safety data but we followed
people even after it was approved and it
ended
up being safe i don't have a major
concern most of the vaccines that make
it this far
don't usually have long-term
consequences i think it's important to
study that
but to me i don't think there's going to
be a signal here and i think that
in the middle of a pandemic you also
have to weigh the risk and the benefit
and i do think
that the vaccines the way we're seeing
them now are really
it's the benefit that's outweighing any
risk that that we have with not having
the long-term data
do you plan to get the vaccine amish
i do plan to get the vaccine as soon as
i'm in an eligible group i am a health
care worker and take care of covet
patients
so i may be in the first priority group
so i will uh gladly get this vaccine
we know um pfizer and biotech say that
their vaccine is 95
effective and and i know that they were
ecstatic about
that number 95 why is that number so
impressive the number is so impressive
because we never thought that a first
generation vaccine
using a new technology would reach those
types of uh that that level of
protection from symptomatic covalent we
were looking at 50 60
that's what we would have been happy
with but to see them really
hit it out of the ballpark 90 percent
really made people uh
take a step back and understand that
this technology does have a lot of
promise not just for covet
but for future infectious disease
vaccines as well
we know that vaccine denial is likely to
be an issue on both sides of the
atlantic there will definitely be
some safety concerns among the public
how many people
will need to be vaccinated to ensure
herd immunity and to stop this pandemic
it's likely going to be maybe 70 80
percent of the population if you assume
that everybody has the same risk of
of transmitting the infection it may be
also
the fact that we're not first looking at
herd immunity here we're looking to try
and decrease the the virulence of this
infection
to be able to stop people from needing
to be hospitalized so we may be able to
give
our hospitals breathing room before we
get near that herd immunity threshold so
it's important to remember that this
vaccine
because it is so effective is likely to
really be able to
to take the pressure off of hospitals
and take the pressure off icu beds and
ventilators
and that's really what's driving a lot
of the public health concern about this
virus that's what flattening the curve
is about it's about keeping it below
hospital capacity
how do you think governments and public
health officials should deal with
this vaccine skepticism that we that we
see
we have to really be as transparent as
possible about the process that led to
the development of these vaccines
what the clinical trials show in terms
of both the safety and the efficacy
try to be able to answer any question
that may come up tell people what we
know what we don't know and really
detail them on all of the
the benefits that this vaccine may
provide and help them make this risk
benefit calculation we have to be
proactive we cannot be reactive
because the anti-vaccine groups will
already be going after this vaccine
prior to its prior to its arrival you
know and from expecting too little to
expecting too much from these
vaccines i want you to take a listen to
what mark ryan said today he's with the
world health organization take a listen
some people think that vaccine will be
in a sense the the solution the unicorn
we've all been chasing
it's not adding vaccines is going to
give us a huge chance
but if we add vaccines and forget the
other things
culver does not go to zero amish are you
concerned that once
the first vaccine injection is given
are you concerned that we'll see people
drop social distancing stop wearing face
masks and let down their guard
we're already seeing people let down
their garden i do think that there is
that danger
you have to remember that the vaccine
isn't going to be a magic bullet unless
it's coupled with
a lot of other things until we get
across a herd immunity threshold and
it's going to take
a process of years to get the world
vaccinated so coven 19 is not going to
go
miraculously to zero we will still need
to think about
what measures we need to do to keep
ourselves safe
especially for those who aren't able to
get the vaccine or who the vaccine
doesn't work for
remember not everybody's going to be in
a priority group so so this is going to
be important that we have to get through
this
process by by using a lot of the common
sense things we've been doing from the
beginning wearing a mask
social distancing washing your hands a
lot
all of that's going to continue for some
time even when the vaccine is available
let me ask you before we run out of time
the german health minister says that
covid vaccines will not be
compulsory do you think that's a
sensible policy
it's going to be hard to make a vaccine
compulsory when it's only
available on an emergency use basis i
think once you see full licensure
and a much more robust safety profile
then i think you can see you'll see
schools for example or employers
making these vaccines a requirement as a
condition of entry
but i think in the early roll out of
this vaccine
it's likely going to be just something
that's highly encouraged but not
something that we really have a basis
for uh mandating because of the because
of the lack of all of the long-term
safety data which we won't have for a
couple of years
which would then will lead to the full
licensure of the vaccine i'm missing
dogs at johns hopkins center for health
security amish it's good to have you on
the show we appreciate your time and
your
valuable insights tonight thank you
thank you
now we turn to india where the capital
delhi is considering plans to
reintroduce some lockdown measures
following festive gatherings and a drop
in temperatures
the nation as a whole is bracing for a
spike in cases but
residents in delhi have already seen the
numbers go up
dw meets those at the front line of the
city's battle
with covert 19.
the day is just beginning for ajay
shojala but he knows it will be a long
one
he counted 15 bodies in the morning when
he left the morgue at delhi's largest
covert 19
hospital where he works he will spend
all day at this crematorium he'll help
cremate the body safely
and ensure that people suffering the
shock of losing a family member to the
coronavirus have proper protective gear
as they say their last goodbyes
for the last week rajesh has been
bringing in twice the number of bodies
done earlier
delhi is experiencing its third spike in
covert 19 cases
with close to 100 deaths every day
rajesh was assigned to the mortuary
after many workers before him quit
overwhelmed by the number of corpses
coming in
i had to step over bodies to sort
through the names of the victims
i had to summon all my courage of course
i was scared
i've never seen anything like it in my
life i've never seen so many bodies
still he soldiers on he says someone has
to
here at the lok nayak hospital delhi's
largest coronavirus facility
the spike is evident the severity of the
cases has also risen
as many more seek admission while this
hospital
still has a high number of designated
coronavirus beds available
they only have a handful of free
ventilators
and intensive care units or icu beds
left
this after icu beds at this facility
alone have been quadrupled during the
pandemic
authorities here are confident that
things are under control
but they are also bracing for more cases
more and more people are coming
out of their home so the number may go
up so we have to make a provision for
that also
this is because of the festival time
that large number of people
are there in the markets in the malls
picture halls and social gathering
the authorities are now mapping out ways
to prevent the health care system from
being overwhelmed
with daily cases in delhi crossing the 8
000 mark the national government has now
stepped in
authorities plan to significantly ramp
up testing
increase the number of icu bets and also
deploy
emergency healthcare forces elsewhere in
delhi though
the morgue and the ward are starkly
distant worlds
crowds continue to throng the markets
residents think reimposing restrictions
is unnecessary
there's no need to worry cases are going
up they'll keep rising even during a
shutdown
people go out anyway it won't make a
difference
it's not so dangerous situation right
now if we take some precautions so
it becomes easy for us back at the
crematorium
rajesh strongly disagrees his is the
kind of work that makes him wince when
he sees the markets overflowing
and people crowding together on the
streets
memories of the lockdown may be fading
for those out and about
but rajesh is still afraid to come close
to his three young daughters
and his aging mother but
he is not giving up lockdown fatigue is
not an option
it's only when the pandemic ends that
rajesh can truly go home
you